well for more honest I were joined by a
professor of political science piece of
math uses in Long Beach in California is
the author of the book dollar democracy
good evening to You professor thank you
for joining us now the g7 powers are
seeking broad support to isolate
President Assad high likely at the do
you feel that Rex Tillerson will
persuade Moscow to abandon Assad it is
very unlikely that he'll persuade them
entirely to come out entirely against my
saying they will abandon Assad because
that's one of the longest serving allies
in the Middle East and they have a
strategic partnership because Russia has
two military bases in Syria one is the
only warm water port has the
Mediterranean and this is strategic so
Russia wants the one on the other side
they're also asking a question who will
come after Assad let's suppose the
United States and the allies are able to
knock out Assad then the question is who
will follow him a question that was not
answered in Iraq when autonomous teen
was taken out who would follow is saying
what would follow his fame was an answer
wasn't looking very carefully and this
has to be done very carefully I think
that will be pointed out tomorrow as
well so tillerson has a very major
challenge on his hands tomorrow in
trying to convince the Russians to drop
their support for Assad at this point we
have a lot of imputing saying he doesn't
believe the Assad regime was behind last
week's chemical attack saying the
information about plans fake chemical
attacks in Syria are justifications for
more US missile strikes meanwhile the
White House has accused piercing of
confusing the world of false narratives
what is going on here well the United
States position of course is through our
intelligence agencies report that there
was I be there still studying the
situation but Trump himself of
administration has said that Russia was
I mean that Assad wasn't behind the
attack that he actually dropped the
bombs but all right the intelligence
community are still studying the
situation as of the United Nations to
find out who is really behind this
because that's a very critical question
to answer if it was the rebels possibly
involved in it and that's a whole
different equation if the Assad
government itself was involved once
again after I've been given up their
weapons of chemical weapons back in 2013
ostensibly because Russia was involved
that negotiation and Russia was supposed
to supervise that to make sure the Assad
regime had no more chemical weapons and
today russia says that they don't have
chemical weapons but this was a
rebel-held mad
facturing a storage plant where a bomb
has hit it from the process Syrian Air
Force and created you know the the
chemicals of the terrible situation
which kill so many people but that's
their version of it I think what we
should do is let's do some more research
that's both of people are looking into
it carefully to research more carefully
to see who is really behind this because
that's the key question for the whole
equation is how to resolve it right now
and we are confronting a very serious
situation this could escalate into a war
with Russia between the US and Russia
which would be just totally untenable
we've never fought a role it with a war
with Russia all right since the Russian
Revolution when some of the Allies
invaded Russia and the US troops were on
Russian soil trying to stop the
Bolshevik Revolution since that time
we've never fought a war with Russia and
we've always attempted to stay away from
that professor as you say the key is
finding our periods behind this if it
were to emerge that it wasn't Assad
holly body would that reflect on Donald
Trump it would be a terrible blow to him
and his prestige into his judgment
because he does not even wait more than
a couple of days before you launch those
missiles in retaliation for an alleged
strike that wasn't proven fully so that
would be look very bad on him if that
happens to be the case in 2013 there was
some question about that sarin attack as
well whether it was the government or
the rebels there's a lot of different
research on it saying that could have
been not the government forces back in
2013 in fact a New York Times took that
off of it the list of Assad egregious
activity so we have to wait and see what
the reports will come out this time
around before someone like Trump she
lives had fired those missiles that was
I think premature in my view bearing in
mind that the president is said to have
shares in the company that manufactures
the missiles used last week under his
administration is boosting the defense
budget is this a case dare I said of the
Trump administration looking for a war I
don't think you looking for war to make
money because I looked up his
investments there in Raytheon and he
only made 201 dollars in dividends into
2015 so it's not that much money but I
do think that raising the issue of
conflict of interest when a person is in
office a high office any office actually
public office they should really be
careful about putting their assets and
their income in a blind trust so there's
no conflict of interest possibly I would
eyes between their public policy
interests the public policy decisions
and a private game someone as ancient as
Plato brought this up the philosopher in
Greece in ancient times said that the
gold class the ruling class at that time
in his ideal state should never even own
private property in the case of crunk he
owns 500 businesses around the world and
the blind trusted he says he's
ostensibly put them in he's not lying at
all he's still making money off those
businesses and he also talks to his son
who's supposed to be in charge of the
blind trust very interesting company of
interest that has to be looked at
carefully Professor Peter Mathews thank
you very much for your time this morning
my pleasure thank you